[Aplausos]
listo
Durante los últimos cuatro años los
medios de comunicación dentro y fuera de
Brasil han destacado la faceta más
radical del bolsonarismo
usted va a transmitir sin editar lo que
le estoy diciendo
usted lo va a poner en su canal sin
embargo la mayoría de los electores de
Jair bolsonaro tiene un perfil de
conservador moderado son representantes
de la clase media seducidos por la
agenda presidencial en defensa de la
familia tradicional y contra la
corrupción Nosotros siempre tuvimos
presidentes corruptos ladrones y él
arrancó este tumor maligno
este cáncer diabólico que tenemos en
nuestro país que es una nación rica y
próspera
y hoy nuestro presidente rescató todo
eso él le dio dignidad a la familia
las mujeres están convulsionado porque
él es honesto es un hombre digno de
estar en el lugar en el que está y quién
está
reencontramos a Samuel en bambú un
barrio de la periferia de Río de Janeiro
marcado por un día a día de violencia y
asaltos
que hay para el café hoy
ambos se sienten muy identificados con
la bandera que levanta diario bolsonaro
contra la legalización del aborto y de
las drogas y contra la llamada ideología
de género
yo estoy contra el aborto desde el
momento de la concepción de la Unión de
dos personas Aunque ocurra una fatalidad
todo es permiso de Dios
Dios va a marcar el curso de la manera
que considere oportuna
Samuel que además de agente inmobiliario
también es pastor evangélico valoriza el
respeto que el mandatario muestra hacia
la religión Hugo
reconoce que el señor es Dios cuando
bolsonaro llega a una iglesia las
personas quieren abrazar a evolucionaron
y no es solo en la iglesia evangélica él
también va a las iglesias católicas
cuatro veces por semana Samuel y Selma
acuden a esta iglesia evangélica para
orar junto a otros fieles
en Brasil el 31% de la población se
declara evangélica cerca de 70 millones
de personas
[Aplausos]
durante toda la campaña electoral
bolsonaro intentado ampliar el apoyo de
los evangélicos que en 2018 fueron
esenciales para su elección
comunismo de los socialismo por todo tu
Mouse señor de su sistema que tanto
Además del llamado religioso otro factor
de atracción para las clases medias y
altas ha sido el programa económico
liberal de bolsonaro
es el caso de esta arquitecta que ve con
buenos ojos que haya más privatizaciones
y una reducción de los impuestos para
las empresas brasileñas bolsonaro ha
conseguido demostrar que existe otro
camino antiguamente todo el mundo tenía
vergüenza de decir que era de derecha y
ahora para seguir todo el mundo que es
de derecha es de extrema derecha y no es
verdad un partido extrema derecha es
homofóbico
no acepta los extranjeros en mi caso no
es así no tengo problema con eso solo
quiero un país organizado con una
economía fuerte y libre con menos
presencia del estado y más iniciativa
privada porque creo que así Brasil va a
despegar
raíz verde cola el negocio de Denise
mejoró durante la gestión de bolsonaro
ella destaca que la inflación también
disminuyó gracias a las medidas
gubernamentales
vos sonaron
los resultados de las elecciones
demostraron que el volucionalismo no es
un fenómeno pasajero y también que todos
los sondeos subestimaron la fuerza de
este Movimiento Político que ha
penetrado a fondo en la sociedad
brasileña
cada vez más politólogos reconocen que
el bolsonarismo perdurará en el tiempo
existe una porción de la sociedad
brasileña que es muy conservadora más de
lo que imaginábamos pero aún en cierto
consenso en la ciencia política de qué
bolsonaro consiguió hacer una
conciliación entre esas fuerzas
conservadoras Hay personas con un perfil
más liberal y personas de derecha con un
perfil más ligado a la agenda
conservadora en el campo social él
consiguió centralizar todos estos apoyos
la consolidación del bolsonarismo fue
coadyuvada por el profundo rechazo de un
sector de la sociedad hacia el partido
de los trabajadores el PT fundado en
1980 por Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
desde 1994 este funcionario público votó
a Lula en todas las elecciones
presidenciales hasta que se decepcionó
con el líder de la izquierda dice que
fue por su sed de poder yo estoy en
contra del PT por causa de la corrupción
generalizada y la falta de competencia
Hoy vemos Un gobierno que escogió cargos
técnicos muchos de ellos no han ido bien
pero no hubo nombramientos partidarios
con el PT los nombramientos no
transmitían una seguridad técnica había
detrás un juego político
como es conocida la aversión a Lula y a
su partido es muy fuerte en Brasil en
los sondeos y el rechazo a Lula alcanza
el 41%, pero bolsonaro el 47% de los
electores afirma que jamás le votaría
independientemente del resultado lo que
ha quedado claro es que Brasil seguirá
muy polarizado en los próximos años